I'm delighted that the government has
reached agreement with unions
representing over a million NHS workers
on a fair and reasonable pay settlement
this agreement rightly recognizes the
Fantastic work that our NHS workers like
nurses midwives and paramedics do whilst
also being affordable for the taxpayer
and allowing us to deliver on our
promises to halve inflation and cut NHS
waiting list it's a good example of this
government getting things done and
delivering for the British people you
say it's affordable for the taxpayers
you won't mind telling us how much it's
going to cost them where the money's
going to come from well I think no one
can doubt our commitment to the NHS
after I became prime minister in the
Autumn statement we announced 14 billion
pounds of more funding for the NHS and
social care that's because it's the
country's number one priority it's my
number one priority and that's why it's
well funded and we will make sure that
we continue to deliver on our promise to
cut waiting lists now that we've got
this pay agreement everyone is United
and wanting to deliver the best possible
care for patients up and down the
country and that will be our Focus I've
noticed a completely swerve my question
I mean how much is it going to cost and
you say if it's good for taxpayers where
is the money going to come from
Frontline Services no absolutely not we
are going to be making sure that we
protect all Frontline services with 14
billion pounds of more funding that we
announced at the end of last year no one
can doubt our commitment to making sure
that the NHS is well funded that will
always remain the case and we've got a
great plan in place to make improvements
and you're already seeing the results of
that plan in fact if you look at
ambulance waiting times or waiting times
in a e they're already improving
considerably from a couple of months ago
and we're on track to keep bringing the
waiting list down and with this pay
agreement now everyone is going to be
United behind that and we can deliver
really fantastic quality care for
patients up and down the country that's
what everyone on the NHS wants to do
they're being backed fully to the hilt
to deliver it and I look forward to
doing that for the country okay well
I'll try my best on that one let me try
on whether this is essentially a plan an
outline now for a future uh kind of
negotiations when it comes to strikes
Junior doctors still going on strike
rail workers do is it this idea of a
one-off payment for last year and then a
pay rise is this the kind of Playbook if
you like well look I'm really pleased
that we reached agreement today with
unions representing over a million NHS
workers and we've always been clear we
want to have constructive dialogue with
unions we're serious about finding fair
and reasonable agreements on public
sector pay I think today's agreement
demonstrates that and what I'd say to
all other unions is you know please
don't be striking please come in and
have those talks we've been wanting to
do that and we today's agreement
demonstrates we're serious about it we
don't want disruption for patients we
don't want disruption for school
children in our classroom so you know
please come and get around the table I'm
confident we can find a way through this
today's agreement demonstrates we're
serious about this and we can find
workable Solutions okay just two final
questions first of all on strike itself
you talked about negotiations there but
hasn't this proven just the government's
caved in that if you want to get a
better deal nothing better to do then
simply just go on strike well today's
pay agreement is is fair for NHS workers
we want to make sure that we reward them
and recognize the hard work they do
whether that's nurses paramedics
midwives but it's also fair for
taxpayers and this was important to us
as well it needs to be affordable and it
needs to be consistent with our promise
to halve inflation and then get on to
cutting NHS waiting lists you know
that's why we've had constructive
dialogue today's agreement is fair for
everybody and it was right that we got
to the this type of solution I'm really
pleased that with this behind us now we
are united in wanting to just get on
deliver high quality patient care bring
the waiting list down that's what the
country wants to see that's what we're
going to deliver just my friendly
relating this to the budget you know one
of the reasons that people went on
strike is the cost of living crisis
and and that's linked to inflation but
it's also going to be next month going
to be linked to increased taxes lots of
millions of workers going to pay more
tax for the next month taking money out
of their pocket including nurses and
doctors do you accept that those tax
Rises effectively because there's a
threshold the fiscal drag it's caused is
going to add to the cost of living
crisis the government is actually making
things worse for people the the number
one challenge with the cost of living is
inflation and particularly with energy
bill so if there's one measure from the
budget that I'd ask people to kind of
take away with them it's our continue
plan to support people with the cost of
energy now what we did last year has
made a decision to tax the windfall
profits of energy companies and to use
that money to help cut people's energy
bills and because of the actions we've
taken people are going to receive 1 500
pounds of direct support off their
energy bills last year in this you know
that's the right thing to do and if
there's one thing you take away from the
budget it's that this government is
doing everything it can to help you with
the cost of your energy bills